[Music]
a few days ago
tom holland delivered the first picture
of him in his role as video game hero
and adventurer
nathan drake the opinions about the
outdoor outfit of the spiderman star are
mostly positive so you can
definitely look forward to perhaps more
convincing performance
as young nate of course this is a
relatively big step compared to the
video games where you always play the
much older nade
except for a few sequences it seems that
the movie will develop towards the
prequel story of the first adventures
which is why the main actor seems
unusually young nate's mentor victor
sullivan who's played by mark wahlberg
is also undergoing a rejuvenation
treatment the 49 year old recently
published a video with sully's
characteristic mustache on instagram
if you put wahlberg's appearance next to
the video game character his similarity
is
definitely evident further footage is
provided by nolan north the video game
actor of nathan drake
he recently visited the film set and had
a pleasant chat with tom holland he also
shares a book with the image of the
sailor magellan and a mysterious
artifact with his followers
we are definitely curious to see what
the uncharted team will do with the
upcoming blockbuster
and are looking forward to the estimated
release date on july 16
2021
[Music]